the jurogan experience but that moment
is special because there's value in
suffering
and in today's society we have convinced
ourselves that there is no value in
suffering that the entire role of say
government is to end your suffering
but this is a false promise not only is
it a false promise but
it will create a weak society that is
unable to sustain itself
that's a really important point and i
think there's i think there's deep truth
in that
this is why victimhood politics is so
dangerous and i would say populism is
too i i i
i think the two are almost
indistinguishable from each other
people are always trying to talk about
populism on the right and the left and i
say look well here's what populism is
it's telling you what you feel
it's mirroring your feelings back to you
telling you what you want to hear as
opposed
to the truth because that i i think
that's a decent definition of populism i
don't like it
i don't like people embracing it um it
doesn't just mean hey things that are
good that people are for
well you know what a lot of people are
for hundred dollar checks that are free
that doesn't mean it's a good policy
right that's a good example right people
voted if they voted and said do you want
a hundred thousand dollars
for a year totally everybody would vote
yes yeah why wouldn't you yeah
but is it but is it a sustainable policy
you know of course right of course not
um and the kind of amounts to the to the
i think drastic lurches
and you know welfare policy or
infrastructure spending and all of these
things that we're seeing
it's populism on steroids it's telling
you what you want to hear
and that's not truth it's not truth and
we have to get back to truth and we have
to get away from this victimhood
mentality where we actually
we actually elevate this idea of being
helpless that's what's changed
that's what's changed in the last decade
it used to be that
well you you might feel some shame if
you were the type to you know what you
know what i just i i need some help i
feel bad about it i'm gonna get back on
my feet but i need some help right now
that used to be the sort of american way
all right we need a safety net
nobody would disagree with that we need
a safety net we need to help people who
have truly fallen on hard times who lost
their jobs because of covid
but does that also mean we need to
provide a 1400 check to somebody who
never lost their job and whose biggest
hardship has been zoom meetings
of course not but over 100 million
people were getting checks that never
lost their jobs
a hundred million easily there's a
covenant it's way more it's way more
than that i'm i'm cutting it off at a
hundred million so hold on explain that
to me
when we when we send out checks the
direct cash payments i've always been
against direct cash payments
so these the coveted stimulus checks
yeah
so because they go out to anybody those
checks that didn't lose their jobs
of course what yeah the cutoff was like
75k
a year so that means wait wait a minute
wait a minute that means every federal
well not so people
a lot of federal workers any money
because of the pandemic
still got checks yeah these were never
these were never
based on your situation what
yeah really that's ridiculous i didn't
know that i thought you had to lose your
job
i thought there was a problem yeah wait
a minute so people who
never lost a penny so if you look at
their their their tax
receipts you look at their their uh what
they made in
2019 versus 2020 correct
if they they didn't lose any money yeah
no it's based on
you're just just your income so i think
75k a year was the cut off
but also if you're a married couple 150k
and if you have kids then it's even more
so you've got like i've got like a lot
of active duty military friends
are getting thousands of dollars because
you know they have kids and
but it's like why and they're like why
why am i this is such a waste of
taxpayer money
you know i mean do your duty and go go
spend it on a local business
suffering the money was allocated to
people that lost money because of the
pandemic no no no because we already
have a system for that it's unemployment
insurance
our system works fine for that that and
this is this is always my thing it's
like look i'm in favor
of temporarily boosting payments to
those who are unemployed on unemployed
insurance usually state-run unemployment
insurance runs
at it it's at a formula that would that
would make sure that you're not making
more than you
would have if you were already employed
because you don't want to have a
disincentive to go back to work
right what we did in the initial stages
of the pandemic was increase that to 600
an
extra 600 a week if you're unemployed
i'm okay with that for a few weeks
during hard times the problem is
democrats want to keep it forever
and now every business i talk to is like
i can't hire people i
i have so many job openings right now
can't hire anybody because we still have
it it's 300
a week but we still have it it means
people are getting paid to stay home
there's a distance they're making a
purely rational financial decision
but again that's one conversation that's
that's at least a debate to be had
you know during hard times but the
direct cash payments
that's nuts that's nuts what are the
direct cash
that's the free money that's the free
that's the free money so this is the
people that
even though they still make the same
amount they made in 2019
in 2020 they got a big check for no
reason yep
100 percent that seems crazy and that's
why
did you do the math that's well over 100
million people and they just got it they
didn't ask for it they just received it
so it's not something they're guilty of
yeah yeah they just received it but but
it gets to the cultural argument that
we're talking about
no there was no backlash for this even
on the right i remember
i remember i was i was i was a little
frustrated with the president or
the ex-president donald trump uh the
president i voted for
that uh he was he was pushing for those
two thousand dollar cash payments
i said but don't you think that he was
doing that politically and i didn't vote
that's the point don't you think about
that that's the point that's political
exactly that's exactly the point there's
an incentive now to pay people off with
their own money
and it's not good yeah but it wasn't
don't you think that he was in a
desperation situation
where he just wanted to get reelected i
mean he's coming through this was in
december he was already
he'd already lost oh so in december
after he lost
he still but he didn't think he lost he
he thought he
it's a good conversation he thought he
was going to somehow or another get
reinstated i don't i don't know if he
ever truly believed that but
um he was pushing for it but yeah he
just on the on the victimhood side
that's
this is the demise of the republic when
when when people are comfortable with
being bought off with their own tax
dollars
and being comfortable even more than
that comfortable with being told that
they're victimized and that some other
group
is is responsible for that victimization
right so it's not just
a bad situation they're in the basement
somebody else's someone did it to you
and maybe it's the one percent maybe
it's those those mean corporate giants
and now those corporate giants are
trying to get all woke and get on the
democrats good side
like they always do yeah because you
know they don't because they want to
maintain their little piece of the pie
that's where it gets tricky right where
they manipulate the narrative and they
they
they realize where people's heads are at
so they try to jump on board
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience